[Musique]
dans les jardins créoles traditionnels
c'est un incontournable
le vert vif de ses grandes feuilles
allongées mesurant jusqu'à 70 cm
[Musique]
ces fleurs aux multiples tonalités de
rose et de blanc serré en grappe
suspendu et s'ouvrant sur des notes
jaune la toux maux est facile à
reconnaître
du haut de ses 3 m cette plante
originaire d'asie a su s'imposer dans la
plupart des régions tropicales où elle
séduit par sa beauté mais surtout pour
ses propriétés curatives
ses fleurs ses feuilles ainsi que ses
racines sont traditionnellement utilisés
en décoction en infusion ou encore en
cataplasme pour traiter grippe bronchite
migraine fièvre indigestion ou encore
hypertension artérielle d'où son nom à
tout mot ses nombreuses applications
ancestrales ont donc mené à de
nombreuses recherches scientifiques
s'approfondit
alpine ya zéro bête c'est son nom
scientifique
[Musique]
ses propriétés médicinales se retrouve
dans toutes les parties de la plante
aussi bien dans les feuilles les fleurs
que les rhizomes et les racines
l'extrait du l'essentiel des feuilles
appartenant à la famille chimique des
monos terpènes et des seize khiter peine
contient près d'une vingtaine de
molécules actives comme la signer homme
ou lacarrieu fil n ayant des propriétés
antioxydantes
antilles âge ou antihypertensive
notamment
l'extrait à partir d'éthanol des racines
contient également des molécules actives
ces molécules possèdent des propriétés
antibactériennes
anti-infectieuses antimicrobienne ou
encore larvicide
[Musique]
inscrite à la pharmacopée française
depuis 2012 le parme poursuit des
recherches approfondies sur cette plante
au potentiel médicinales à travers son
projet un nouvel c'est vraiment pour
moore une plante phare de la pharmacopée
martiniquaise jeune et très utilisés
dans les ménages au niveau des travaux
menés au pam on a travaillé sur
différents axes activité antimicrobienne
l'activité anti inflammatoires on a fait
aussi l'activité antioxydante l'étude de
composition dallas tout vaut donc
vraiment différents aspects ont été
étudiées à travers les résultats dont on
dispose aujourd'hui on peut imaginer
différents axes de valorisation donc à
titre d'exemple la valorisation en tant
que complément alimentaire on a une
forte teneur en antioxydants des
minéraux présents des vitamines
également on pourrait mettre au point
des compléments alimentaires avec des
allégations santé du type en
fonctionnement du système immunitaire
alpina 0 bête révèle un intérêt notable
également dans le domaine de la
parfumerie le parme a pu effectuer des
tests par des néo des notes aromatiques
intéressante pour une valorisation
parfumerie ont été relevés sur l'huile
essentielle de feuilles avec des notes
camphre et boisé térébenthine doit de
pain frais
mais attention quel que soit l'usagé que
vous en faites il faut toujours être
prudent si les plantes peuvent soigner
mieux vaut demander conseil à votre
médecin